one of the worst things about the
character of contemporary partisanship
is that because everything has to be
politicized
things just sort of fall on one side or
the other of our politics and people in
one party feel like they have to be
against something because people in the
other have made it their big issue
um and this certainly happened with
family issues I mean the idea that to
talk about providing support for
families is to take a stark polarized
partisan position is I think bizarre we
can certainly argue about how to support
families and I think there may be just
some distinctly left or right ways of
thinking about that but the notion that
there ought to be a role for society as
a whole to provide support for family
formation and for family durability
um it seems to me should be
uncontroversial
um it certainly is controversial and you
know it's just the character of this
moment is that essentially everything is
controversial I mean you can't take any
position without it being identified as
uh in one sense or another a rejection
of the opposite party
um I think family is the foundation of
society that uh and and that's that
that's not
um
that's not because of our kind of
society in particular it's because of
what it is to be a human being
um no yeah that feels fairly Universal
yeah I mean you know human beings are
never born alone they're always born in
families and some one way or another
that's how reformed to be what we become
foreign
[Music]
this week on forward founding editor of
national Affairs magazine and director
of social cultural and constitutional
studies at the American Enterprise
Institute author of Five Books Yuval
Levin joins us on forward this week
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to forward one of the smartest guys
around in terms of how to fix this world
of ours the head of social cultural and
constitutional studies at the American
Enterprise Institute and the founding
editor of national Affairs magazine very
fancy stuff you've all live in you've
all welcome thanks very much for having
me it's great to be here you've written
five books I believe you're a prolific
thinker and one of the most prominent
intellectuals among what's called the
reform conservative movement now you and
I have spoken before and you just struck
me as like an eminently reasonable guy
how does one become a prominent
conservative intellectual like what the
heck is that path
I ask myself all the time
um it's a good question there's no path
there's no path I mean I would say that
um the work I do
it it what what's distinct about it if
anything is that it is kind of in the
intersection of theory and practice uh
my education is really in political
philosophy I have a PhD from the
University of Chicago that's really a
political Theory
but I've spent a lot of time working in
public policy
um I worked for members of Congress I
worked for uh president of the United
States for George W bush as a White
House staffer
um have worked a lot on on public policy
questions on the whole range of domestic
issues and in a sense it's the fact that
I tend to see the policy questions in
light of the underlying Theory questions
and vice versa
that sometimes occasionally gives me
something to say that other people don't
see or don't think and I would say
that's been the distinct character of
the sort of work I do but I worked in
Government after graduate school for a
decade or so and then into the think
tank world
and
um you know I don't I I don't know what
intellectual means exactly as a
practical matter but
um the the work I've tried to do is try
to help people think about the the rush
of events in terms of deeper questions
and I guess that's one thing that
intellectually minded people engaged in
politics try to do so you've been a part
of let's say broadly speaking the
Republican party or the conservative
thought movement for a number of years
and you relatively famously pinned an
essay in this anti-trump never Trump
kind of uh milieu it was like up up like
a bunch of conservative intellectuals
were like hey this is totally not the
guy not what we're about was that a
difficult choice for you
no but at that point it really was not
so this was in a a special issue of
National Review
um at the very beginning of 2016. so at
the beginning of the primary uh process
and the theme of the issue was really
um in a sense why Donald Trump is not a
conservative and why conservatives
should not support him
um I certainly think that's a very easy
case to make Donald Trump was not a
conservative he was uh fundamentally
hostile to American institutions and
conservatives are fundamentally
protective of those
and that was the essence of the case I
made and and a case I continue to make
in a variety of ways throughout his
presidency and since then I am a
conservative and it is because I'm a
conservative that I that I rejected
Donald Trump and that I thought he was
not fit to be president
um and that certainly has always
remained my view
you know it was a challenging time
within the right because obviously that
was a very divisive question for the
entire period of his presidency and it
remains so in some ways
um
I think in some ways it divided people
whose top priority was to defeat the
Democrats from people whose top priority
it was to advance a certain kind of
vision of American Life
um and you know maybe that's a little
unfair to put it that way and and uh you
know politics often involves uh hard
choices but for me the view that Donald
Trump should not be president was not a
hard choice and not a hard case to make
so you made that case
um did you experience a lot of hostility
or blowback uh and there were some
people that made that case who then
recanted a little bit later because that
case was being made in the beginning of
2016 when Trump was not president he
then became president which uh warmed a
lot of people up to him I suppose
yeah I there certainly were I mean if
you look at that issue of national
reviews some of those people who wrote
those pieces did change their minds uh
certainly not everybody but some did
um yeah I mean there was blow but I mean
look to work or in and around Politics
as you know much better than I do
um is not only to make friends but also
to make adversaries and a lot of what
you have to say gets criticized and so
there was certainly a lot of criticism
around
uh uh critiques of trump within the
right
um
I thought that what happened everything
that happened after that issue came out
to me only confirmed my concerns that
Trump was not fit to be president and
that in a particular way that he was not
suited to thinking about the
responsibilities of that job yeah and
that that job is all responsibilities
um and so that inability is ultimately
an unfitnessed
um certainly that remained a divisive
view on the right in some ways it still
remains a divisive view on the right but
um you know in the world that I that I
work in the of kind of conservative
writers and thinkers
um there were a lot of people who shared
that view it was by no means uh a a
notion that isolated me
um but not everybody shared it by any
means and um the Fight Continues let me
first applaud you on a personal level
for your integrity and conviction uh and
courage
um because I'd imagine there were a lot
of people that might have thought that
but wouldn't have put pen to paper
wouldn't have put their names out there
and then as you said some of them
changed their minds when it was a little
bit more politically expedient you know
I [ __ ] just said that there were
there were people for whom that really
did take courage especially people in
our politics who faced voters
um which I don't have to do
um and so for me
you know if I don't express my actual
opinion then it's hard to to imagine
what purpose my work would have and it
it didn't take real courage not really
um there were certainly plenty of people
who who took much more courage than I
required in order to stand for principle
over this period and uh I I admire them
my you know my job is to express my own
opinion so
um I don't consider it Courage I just
think that's that's that's the very
minimum I could do
well unfortunately doing your job in the
face of adversity is not something that
everyone chooses so really again
um my my personal thanks and I I'm
imagining that other people would join
me in that I liked How You just defined
conservatism you said conservatives
defend institutions uh and you wrote a
book
um that makes the case or called a time
to build
um around investing in American
institutions first how do you define an
institution as independent from let's
say an organization yeah thank you I
think it's a very important question and
it's certainly important for thinking
about what conservatives are for but
it's important in general for thinking
about the kinds of challenges we face in
our country now
a lot of those challenges seem like
dissolution like breakdown
um and it's hard to understand them in
individualistic terms uh if we're just
individuals trying to somehow connect
with one another
uh then it would be hard to see how we
would simultaneously be experiencing the
kinds of intense political divisions we
see the sort of alienation that people
feel in their own lives the increases in
uh in suicide rates that we've seen the
opioid epidemic I think all these things
are connected and yes that they're
connected around a breakdown of
Institutions now the term institution as
you suggest is very Broad and capacious
there are a lot of kind of academic
definitions of it but for for for the
purpose of this kind of conversation
about the condition of our society I
think of Institutions as the the durable
forms of our common life they are the
shapes the structures of what people do
together
so some institutions are organizations
they have a real kind of corporate form
a company a university uh a a you know a
civic association a hospital but some
institutions are durable forms of a
different kind maybe they're shaped by
laws or by Norms but without that kind
of corporate structure the family is the
first and foremost institution of any
society you could talk about a
particular tradition or profession as an
institution the rule of law is an
institution that they're durable is one
essential fact about them so an
institution keeps its shape over time
and so it shapes human relationships in
that Arena of life but most important as
I think about it is and most distinct
about an institution is that it's a form
in the deepest sense a structure a
contour a shape that organizes common
action and so an institution is a social
form it's not just a bunch of people
it's a bunch of people who are ordered
together to achieve a common purpose
pursue a common goal and that ordering
together gives each of them a place in
relation to the others and in relation
to what they want to do together
and that means also that institutions by
their nature are formative of us they
not only shape our interactions with one
another they shape us they shape our
character our habits our expectations so
that there's there's such a human type
in the world as you know an accountant
or a lawyer there's such a human type in
the world as a mother or uh or or a
Catholic and that has to do very much
with institutional formation and a lot
of the breakdowns we find are breakdowns
in that kind of formation when
institutions fail to form people
properly we find that we can't connect
We Don't Belong we feel isolated and
alienated and for that reason I think in
this moment it's really important to
think about our social situation in
terms of institutions
thank you
[Music]
it's 2022 and just about everything you
do is made just for you with the
possible exception for most people still
of your coffee despite the fact that you
really have strong feelings about your
coffee let's change that right now go to
trade coffee and take a coffee quiz to
get started they will send you your
first bag made just for you and if you
don't love it they will replace it for
free it's a coffee subscription with no
hassle change your frequency you can
modify it or even cancel at any time and
for our listeners right now Trade coffee
is offering you a total of twenty
dollars off your first three bags when
you go to drinktrade.com Yang to get
started take their quiz at
drinktrade.com Yang and start your
journey to your perfect cup of coffee
that's drinktrade.com Yang for 20 bucks
off your first three bags you'll be glad
you did
[Music]
so the institution that you mentioned uh
that I that pops to mind for me is
family
um and I recently wrote an op-ed about
the struggles among boys and men that
are unfortunately now kind of
self-propagating where if you have men
who are failing then you have lower
rates of family formation
um you have kids who are being born to
single moms I think it's up to over 40
percent in the US now there are adverse
outcomes among boys in particular who
are brought up in in those uh types of
environments
um so I I'm and I'm a I don't know about
your personal situation I'm a dad myself
so I've got uh yes uh how old are your
kids my kids are nine and eleven wow
I've got a nine year old and a
six-year-old uh and I I have said to
people Yuval I never would have even
considered running for president if not
for my experiences as a parent where
when our first son was born he was
autistic we did not know that it was a
very very difficult baby and toddler uh
and the strain on the family was uh
extraordinary
um
and
I remember thinking I have no idea how
people could get through this alone
because in our case uh you know it was
my wife Evelyn and I
um and I ran for president because I
thought I might be able to help the
situation for people who are struggling
uh at that level like at home uh
um with the family
um and so that this is to me like a
building block as you suggest is no more
important institution
um and I proposed something that
um I took a little bit of heat for but
mainly people liked I said hey I think
we should just pay for marriage
counseling for anyone who wants it like
if you're struggling in a relationship
and you wanna have someone uh help you
with your relationship with your partner
that's a social win like if you stay
together it's a win you know like I
could do the math audit if you wanted to
but
um you know it et cetera Etc
um so uh that's like the the first
institution I think of and for whatever
reason
um we're in a strange time where I think
if you say something about Pro family
um like that that gets freighted
politically in certain ways one of the
worst things about the character of
contemporary partisanship is that
because everything has to be politicized
things just sort of fall on one side or
the other of our politics and people in
one party feel like they have to be
against something because people in the
other have made it their big issue
um and this certainly happened with
family issues I mean the idea that to
talk about providing support for
families is to take a stark polarized
partisan position is I think bizarre we
can certainly argue about how to support
families and I think there may be just
some distinctly left or right ways of
thinking about that but the notion that
there ought to be a role for society as
a whole to provide support for family
formation and for family durability
um it seems to me should be
uncontroversial
um it certainly is controversial and you
know it's just the character of this
moment is that essentially everything is
controversial I mean you can't take any
position without it being identified as
uh in one sense or another a rejection
of the opposite party
um I think family is the foundation of
society that uh and and that's a that
that's not
um
that's not because of our kind of
society in particular it's because of
what it is to be a human being
um no yeah that feels fairly Universal
yeah I mean you know human beings are
never born alone they're always born in
families and some one way or another
that's how reformed to be what we become
so you've been a part of
politics and public life in some form
for uh gosh not to date you but you know
like going on a couple of decades uh and
during that time there's been a real
erosion maybe even collapse of
institutional trust yeah um how do you
see that decline as tied to this
polarization that you're describing
which I I'm sure you'd agree has gotten
much much worse in recent years yeah
yeah absolutely I mean I I there's no
question that we're living through a
period of declining even collapsing
public confidence in in institutions
that much is uh it's almost a cliche by
now to say so and and the data behind it
is very very strong Decades of of public
opinion research it's not just political
institutions
um it's it's every kind of institution
from from religion to uh to Big Business
to Banks to the media to universities
and certainly the institutions of our
government just have less of the
Public's confidence now than they used
to
um you know there are a variety of
reasons why that happens I mean in some
ways it is over determined but there's
some reasons that are especially
distinct to our time I mean I think you
know one kind of universal reason for
mistrust is corruption and there's
plenty of corruption in our time but
there's plenty of corruption in every
time it doesn't quite explain the
trajectory
um similarly incompetence you know
sometimes you don't trust an institution
just because it doesn't do its job very
well and there are always reasons for
that kind of mistrust but I think one
thing that's distinct in our time is a
sense that our institutions are not
forming trustworthy people that is as I
talked about institutions before you
think of them as shaping a certain kind
of human type and oftentimes the reason
you trust that human type has to do with
boundaries that are set by the
institution right I trust my accountant
not so much because she just knows all
the tax laws I hope she does but because
there are things an accountant would
never do would never sign a name to
and in that and for that reason I can
trust what she does do
um you could say that about a lot of
Professionals in particular but a lot of
people in general who are shaped by
institutions it's the constraint that
gives us Trust
there are things a journalist who's
really a journalist wouldn't say without
checking there are things a scientist
would not claim without evidence you
should check on that journalism one I
know I know who's a journalist right if
we were to trust institutions if we were
to trust journalists if we can think
back to a time when we might have that
would have been the reason why and I
think in our time and you know as as
what you say about journalists suggests
in our time we've lost the sense that
people are actually constrained by these
institutional boundaries and instead we
have a sense that people use the
institutions that they're part of as as
platforms for themselves you can say it
in journalism uh you know a lot of a lot
of political journalists now if you
check in on Twitter right now you'd find
some Elite political journalists just
building their own brand not acting
within an institution within layers of
editing and verification but Standing On
Top of Institutions I'm a New York Times
Reporter and so you should care what I
think and acting as individual tools
liberated from those kinds of
constraints those people become very
hard to trust
um and wow a lot of our institutions now
essentially Elevate individuals that way
rather than constraining them in a way
that makes them trustworthy that's true
in the media it's true in the academy
it's true in politics a lot of people
now run for Congress not to be the human
type that is a legislator but to build a
personal following to build their brand
to build their social media following or
to get a better time slot on cable news
and what they're doing is not
recognizably institutional and therefore
is very hard to trust I think a lot of
our loss of trust has had to do with
that and it's connected to return to
your question it's connected very much
to partisan divisions and polarization
because a lot of what people do with
that with that prominence that they get
by Standing On Top of Institutions as
platforms is participate in the culture
War
and so
um you know being a prominent pastor
means you get to show that you are part
of this team and not that team being a
prominent Professor means that you have
a platform for uh expressing a affinity
and solidarity with your own team and
the culture War obviously it happens in
the media obviously it happens in
Corporate America and in politics and so
in that sense I think the weakening of
institutional constraints has a huge
amount to do with the intensification of
polarization and partisan animosity in
in this Century well you like one of
these old school anti-corruption
institutionalists where you're like hey
you know you're representing this uh
very important uh organization or Argus
body so you should never be beating your
chest in that way I can see why you
didn't like Trump
no kidding I mean here's a guy who was
not shaped by any of the institutions
that normally shape our presidents right
he's the first President we ever had who
had not held any public office before of
any kind
um and I resemble that but continue
is that he doesn't take it he doesn't
take his cues from those formative
political institutions and I think that
that has expressed itself in everything
that he had done before he had basically
been a performer
um and he wanted to be president to be a
performer on a bigger stage and that's
what he was and you know I I think that
ultimately we we always have to be in
order to have any kind of Integrity in
life we have to ask ourselves given the
role that I have here how should I
behave and maybe that role is I'm
somebody's father or I'm a professional
or I'm a neighbor or a friend
um given that how should I behave in
this situation that's what that's what a
person with Integrity asks themselves
and I think that this kind of
deformation of our institutions that
encourages people to just think of
themselves as performers takes away the
incentive to ask that question and the
result is just a a lot of
irresponsibility
you know what I love to do that you love
to do sleep yep you do it eight hours a
day if you're lucky and yet you might
not have invested properly in that
mattress that you freaking snuggle up to
every single night why not have a
mattress that's made just for you it's
personalized to the way you want to
sleep your body type your sleep
preferences everyone is unique do you
like it hot do you like it cool do you
like it soft do you like it firm heck I
don't want to know but you know who does
want to know Helix Helix sleep is going
to send you the best mattress of your
life they were awarded the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by GQ
and Wired Magazine just go to
helixsleep.com Yang and take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
with a 10 year warranty you get to try
it out for a hundred nights and risk
free imagine trying something for 99
nights and sending it back but they know
you're not going to send it back because
they have that much confidence in their
mattress and so do I Helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
Helix sleep.com slash Yang best mattress
around Helix sleep.com slash yang
[Music]
so I have a question for you that you
can go back in in your memory banks what
did you think of the Andrew Yang
presidential campaign back in the day
and I share this because uh
um I have written about I don't know if
you've read it but I've written about
how the
campaign itself forced me to become
something of a performer because I
needed to survive in an ecosystem where
I didn't have a lot of natural
advantages
and so I would let people into a certain
degree people got excited about the
campaign because they had a sense of me
there were certainly times when I didn't
do things that would be conventionally
presidential
and I'll confess to you as well that
when I was starting my campaign it was
so difficult and painful because I would
address small groups of people who were
there as a courtesy to be like all right
let's see what this guy has to say and
then I would act like
I kind of imagined a presidential
candidate was supposed to act and the
whole thing was a bit of a dud uh
honestly and my team was like whoa we
gotta freaking work on this uh and as
time passed I became more
uh comfortable but also more Dynamic
more personable I would swear as an
example
um and that's something that's pretty
natural for me because I uh swear a lot
um no no some people would look at that
and say like oh I really like this guy
because it's very very genuine and other
people like oh look at this this guy is
totally non-serious so I don't know if
you were keeping up with me in the
presidential campaign back then but I'm
I'm just throwing this out um as a
question because I'm curious really more
than anything well look I I think that
what distinguishes performative politics
from substantive politics has to do with
how people understand the goal of what
they're engaged in and on that front I
don't think that what you were doing was
fundamentally performative it was about
it was about solving public problems
whereas if you think about some of the
politicians who most drive you crazy on
either party oh my gosh I can think of
so many where you can tell they don't
actually think the things they're saying
yeah and the the performance is the
point they're trying to channel a
certain kind of uh frustration or
resentment on the part of the voters
they're trying to reach and they want to
show that they express the same view
they're not speaking to it they're not
they're not trying to assuage it they're
not trying to answer it they're not
trying to address the underlying problem
they're trying to channel the
frustration
um and the sentiment and oftentimes
that's a negative sentiment naturally
and so
um they end up being basically kind of
negative performers
um you know I I think Donald Trump was
the epitome of that but he's not by any
means the only person who operates that
way who fundamentally thinks of himself
as a performer in the public Arena
I do think that's very different from
trying to adjust yourself to the demands
of the media environment
um and you know in order to get heard
the question is to get hurt saying what
and if the answer to that has to do with
how to deploy government in ways that
might address public problems then I
think that's what a politician ought to
be doing if the answer is to have a
particularly prominent
venue and platform
from which to participate in the circus
of our culture War then I don't think
that's an appropriate use of politics
and you know a lot of what happens in
our public life now looks like the
latter I mean I I in particular worry on
that respect about Congress I I think
Congress needs to be at the center of
our system of government and it needs to
be at the center as a venue for
accommodation and bargaining that's the
purpose of the institution and it's
become instead a platform for commentary
um which both takes itself out of the
center and doesn't do the work of
Engagement and accommodation and
bargaining and you know I think that a
lot of the problems we face now in our
politics begin from that dysfunction we
can get into some of your ideas around
reforming Congress right now uh I was
going to head there eventually but we
might as well well uh we'll touch on it
directly since you raised it uh you
think that Congress potentially should
be a whole lot bigger than it is now uh
explain yeah I mean my my attitude about
Congress my ideas about how to change
Congress are all rooted in this problem
I've just described which is that in
essence the purpose of the institution
is to address public problems through
bargaining and accommodation to resolve
public differences peacefully by uh by
allowing people with different views to
negotiate we can only happen members of
Congress off from cable TV but continue
that'd be great that big red I mean one
of the ideas I have for Congress is
basically to end the televising of
committee hearings which I think has
done terrible damage to Congress
um and the reason is because you can't
you can't talk you can't negotiate you
can't bargain there's no such thing as
bargaining in public if you're watching
bargaining in public you're watching a
show and the real work will happen
somewhere else and that's what's
happened to Congress is most of what
happens is a show if you if you if you
attend a hearing you're basically
looking at people who are recording
YouTube videos to use later they're not
talking to each other at all and when
work has to get done it gets done in the
leaders offices you know at midnight
before a government shutdown and then
everybody's frustrated by that but where
else are they supposed to do it
um I think that kind of thinking about
the meaning of transparency and the
reach of it is is one way to think about
reforming Congress as you say I also
think there's room for expanding the
House of Representatives
um the house is supposed to be the most
representative of the institutions of
our constitutional system
um it's directly elected every two years
members are constantly answerable to the
people and part of the logic of it
originally was that members would be
relatively close to their constituents
and so originally every member of the
House represented about 30 000 people
um and the idea was the house would grow
after every census so that that number
was kept in some check and it did grow
after every census from 1790 until 1910.
and then after the 1910 census
there's some dispute on my political
sciences about exactly why my sense of
the evidence is that this happened
because continuing to grow the house
would have made the house more and more
Catholic given the patterns of
immigration after 1910 but whatever the
reason uh Congress decided to stop
growing the house and rather than grow
with every census they began to
reapportion to divide this the existing
number of seats 435 seats in the House
in different ways larger and larger
population exactly so
at this point every member of the House
represents uh more than three quarters
of a million people almost 800 000
people
um that means that some house members
represent more people than Senators do
and it also means that it is very hard
for representation to happen in the way
that it was originally conceived now I
don't think we can get back to thirty
thousand that would mean the house would
have to be you know 3 000 members or so
and that's you have to balance this
against the need for the house to be a
venue for negotiation a face-to-face
Institution
but what I would propose is that if the
house had kept growing after 1910 in the
way it had before there would now be
about 150 more members than there are
and so I think by by Statute you don't
need to change the Constitution for this
Congress should grow the House of
Representatives by 150 members and then
keep growing after every census as it
did in the first uh 120 years of the
Republic I think it that would improve
representation it would also help to
balance the Electoral College some
because each State's Electoral College
votes are a function of that state of
the size of that State's Congressional
Delegation so there'd be a little bit
less of an imbalance between large and
small states
um and I tend to think that kind of
change would be a shot in the arm for
other changes bringing in 150 new
members all at once would mean members
would think about what else needs to
change maybe we need to rethink the
budget process the committee system
there are all kinds of changes now that
need to change the incentives that
members face so that the incentive is
not to be a performer on a stage but to
be a legislator in in negotiation with
others
there's no Silver Bullet for getting
there but I think there are a series of
reforms that could gradually make the
difference you'd also need some
electoral reforms and those are harder
to come by but we have to think about
the Congress in terms of institutional
incentives if we want people to behave
better we've got to change the the the
motives that drive them to behave the
way they do now
thank you
[Music]
it's the winter it's a tough time you
look outside and you're like huh kind of
great now sometimes you can just cheer
yourself up uh you know with a little
bit of this and that but sometimes you
need a little bit more it's one reason
why I'm so proud for this podcast to be
sponsored by betterhelp online therapy
you invest a lot in a lot of things but
why not invest in your own mental health
it's like having an on-demand therapist
because that's exactly what it is it's a
person that's trained to speak to you
they're on call no one needs to know
over 2 million people have already used
better help online therapy to feel
better about themselves and if this
sounds like something that would benefit
you you should definitely try it this
podcast is sponsored by betterhelp and
forward listeners get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com Yang that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h
elp.com Yang check it out I can spell
better help you should too
betterhelp.com yang
[Music]
would you agree that we should also be
examining uh multi-member districts so
that you have different points of view
that that are represented yeah I I think
there's room to experiment with changes
in how members especially members of the
House are elected
um multi-member districts I mean in a
sense the logic behind multi-mover
districts but also behind various forms
of ranked Choice voting is to allow for
more of a fine-grained representation in
Congress so that there aren't just two
categories of people in America
Republicans and Democrats there are all
kinds of people in America and we do
have a two-party system but within that
two-party system you could have a lot
more constructive factionalism where
there are more uh Urban Republicans
there are more rural Democrats there are
more people with a a broader variety of
views
and I think that
part of the reason we don't see that now
has to do with electoral reforms that
were undertaken in the 1970s basically
the creation of party primaries
um which put a lot of power over
candidate selection in the hands of very
small groups of party activists tend to
be they tend to be the most
ideologically uh
divided of the of the voters of the
electorate and therefore the parties
just look like those people those are
the people who get nominated
I think we we need to look for ways to
allow a greater diversity of views to be
represented within both party coalitions
uh to me that points toward rank Choice
voting I I think it's also very
worthwhile to experiment with
multi-member districts we used to have
multi-member districts in the house that
wouldn't be a really an innovation for
American politics
um it's been illegal uh since the 1960s
and again it's a matter of passing a law
and allowing states to experiment with
it one concern I do have about
multi-member districts is just that
there's less there's less personal
accountability within one District a
member could say well talk to the other
member from this District because she's
more like you
um and I I don't think that's a good
idea I think we want to be careful about
making sure that every constituent has
someone whose job it is to really
represent them in Congress but I think
it's worth the experiment because there
clearly need to be changes in how the in
the kind of people who choose to run for
office who decide that this is for them
and some of that has got to involve
changes in the kind of election of
election rules that now uh create all
the incentives
ranked Choice voting you know creates an
incentive for people to try to be
everybody's second choice and I think
that's a very healthy way to think about
how to get more people engaged and a
different kind of personality for our
politics you know what one thing I love
about the way you approach these issues
uh you've always your your uh modernizer
or strengthener at heart you look up and
say wait a minute uh why did you stop
growing at 1910 uh you know it would be
extraordinarily difficult for one human
to represent 800 000 Americans like 30
000 is like a very large college campus
800
000.
you know like a medium-sized city or a
large city even the fact that you're
thinking about ways for these
institutions to advance and evolve I
think really is uh the best impulse uh
and certainly you and I uh are aligned
on that uh you wrote an essay recently
that I thought was very dark and
difficult but also extraordinarily
accurate
um where you talked about how fewer bad
things are happening because fewer
things are happening
that you could look up and say well you
know if you were teenage pregnancies uh
well and that's good but it's also
because people are dating less
interacting less staying at home more
same thing with drunk driving fatalities
going down but it turns out that just no
one's driving because everyone's staying
at home uh and UC institutions as a
force for moderation uh which is one
reason you like them or formation as you
say uh uh and now know that there's like
a different issue which is that instead
of having this raging impulse that then
needs moderation it's like the impulse
isn't even there like people are
defeated before they even decide to
leave the home uh which by the way is
something I'm also very very concerned
about
um and you take it a step further where
you talk about the culture as it stands
right now it instills a kind of risk
aversion because of the performative
aspects of expression replacing action
which I also agree with
um I I'd love to have to discuss
um first like the these points of the of
uh your essay and then what you think
can or should be done well thank you
very much first of all I I I really like
the way you put the point that is that
thinking about improving or
strengthening our society means thinking
about modernizing and reinforcing our
institutions I think it's very important
not to not to look backward when we
think about social change and I'm a
conservative I think we have a lot to
learn from our past as a society but
time never moves backward and so the
question for us when it comes to how do
we improve things is always how do we go
from here to a better working set of
Institutions or a better working society
and there's a very very powerful
tendency in our culture now to Nostalgia
it's actually true on both the left and
the right to think about kind of late
20th century mid-20s which version of
the past do you prefer you've all
exactly you go back to the economy of
the 50s which oddly the left wants to do
or do you go back to the culture of the
50s which is right ones to do I don't
think you can go back to either of those
so let's think about where we want to go
forward to
um I you know frankly in part this is
probably because so many of our
political leaders were born in the 1940s
um are going to turn 80 in the 2020s and
it is odd for a country to choose to be
governed by such an elderly uh class of
people I think the generational change
that's coming is going to force us to
think about a new set of problems and
this this essay that you point to from
uh just a month or so ago try to think
about social breakdown in in these terms
where as you say we're we're used to
thinking about social breakdown as
disorder as an excess of energy people
jumping in too fast having kids too soon
having sex too soon uh rushing into life
and that certainly is one important
driver of social breakdown and social
trouble but what stands out about the
the the the statistics about family
formation and uh and other social
indicators lately is that there's an
even more powerful or more fundamental
Force which is a kind of withdrawal from
society a sort of alienation or or loss
of confidence and loss of energy that
looks like people not getting going
rather than getting going too hard too
fast
um and pushing too soon and
that that at first can look like as you
say like good news like divorce rates
are really low uh the teen pregnancy
rate is extremely low
um abortion rates have been falling now
for 20 years these are good things but
when you look into them you realize that
divorce rates are very low because
marriage rates are even lower
um and uh you know there are a few
abortions because there are fewer
pregnancies much fewer
um and you know in turn there's also
just less social engagement less
marriage less uh less family formation
and in some important respects this has
to do with people not feeling confident
about jumping into society not feeling
like this is for me this is the path for
my life it's especially the case with
men yep
um young men feeling like they're just
gonna stay on the sidelines
um there's no path for them to get to
something that looks like flourishing
and instead they're gonna pass their
time
um you know I mean it's a cliche to say
at home playing video games but it's at
some level that's what's happening and
we have to think about how to get people
engaged how to get people to think about
how to flourish how to get people to
take risks both by shielding them from
the worst kind of catastrophes that can
come if things go wrong and there you do
need help from public systems that can
make sure that if a risk goes wrong it's
not the end for you
but also to help people see the promise
of getting involved in family getting
involved in work getting into the
economy pushing a little bit further to
get that one more level of Education
that can let you rise one more bit in
our society
we're not used to thinking about this
kind of problem and I think that in the
coming years when we think about social
breakdown this is much more of what
we're going to have to think about how
to help people get started rather than
how to restrain people from rushing too
fast yeah give them a catalyst or a
reason to get out there to Aspire to to
the point where you think that a risk
aversion has been built up in part by
this emphasis on expression versus
action were you thinking of social media
when you said that uh and I I'm are you
not on social media because if you're
not that makes you smarter then uh let's
say me well I I'm not on Twitter
um I took a look at Twitter about it
must have been 10 years ago or so and I
thought this is really not for me and
I've never looked back I'm glad I'm not
on Twitter I'm sure I miss important
things but on the other hand I think
Twitter deforms the political culture
and larger culture of our society in
some really profound ways I'm barely on
social media otherwise I I have a
Facebook account that I used to keep up
with my family
um but I don't do anything work related
on it I don't engage in political
debates on social media
um I I think there's a real danger to
the ways in which people now use social
media and part of the danger has to do
with this kind of confusion of uh
expression with action the sense that if
you just give something a thumbs up or
or you know click on that heart emoji
then you've done something you've really
stepped up and showed you really made a
difference yeah and you know I mean
you've literally done nothing and so I I
think that we we now confuse expression
and action in ways that keep us from
acting you really see it in politics
where so much of what happens is totally
ephemeral
um and you know it's about winning like
a medical action not even a daily press
cycle it's about winning like a press
half hour
exactly exactly it's a second and
sometimes even you know you social media
can be used to enable some political
action you know actually getting out on
the street but that's ephemeral too that
turns out not to have any structure
behind it any institutions behind it and
so it's not real political power it
hasn't shown the country anything and
um you know part of this is that
confusion of expression and action I
also think that there are ways that that
social media just encourages us and
enables us to live in bubbles to a very
very dangerous degree I you know as I
say I'm on Facebook I'm not I don't
engage in political debates on Facebook
but I see them because you can't miss
them and I would say I because of the
peculiar nature of my of of my the
combination of my demographics and my
work I'm on the one hand uh a
foreign-born Jewish PhD I grew up in New
Jersey and live in Maryland so I know a
lot of people on the left
on the other hand I'm a conservative I
work in the conservative opinion world
and I know a lot of people on the right
and what you find on Facebook is that
these two worlds of friends of mine are
completely unconnected to each other
they each think that they are angry at
the other but in fact they are each
angry about something that the other has
never heard about
um they're complaining about things that
are entirely part of their own culture
and so is the other side and they're not
engaging with each other they're not
hearing each other they're not becoming
aware of one another's priorities in any
way that you would in a real world
debate and you know that allows the
temperature to rise without anything
being achieved the parties simply talk
about each other rather than to each
other I think social media has a huge
amount to do with why that can happen
thank you
I have run small businesses and bigger
businesses for a couple decades now and
the big lesson is that you have to use
your time effectively you know what's
not an effective use of your time
waiting in the post office you can do
better than that and with stamps.com you
can skip that trip and focus on the
things your business actually needs to
grow yep stamps.com will let you print
postage right from your computer save
you money more importantly it will save
you time because time is where it's at
stop overpaying for shipping with
stamps.com sign up with promo code Yang
for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial free postage and a
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code Yang give yourself your
time back never wait in line at a post
office again stamps.com enter code yang
foreign
[Music]
you get asked often to speak on the
future of the Republican party I'd
imagine that you're something of an
attractor to uh let's say conservatives
and Republicans who have grave concerns
about Donald Trump
so I I will share with you my prognosis
for what's coming
um which you know is not nothing that
far out is that Trump uh runs for
president uh wins the Republican
nomination is the Republican nominee uh
that is coming down the pike and will
challenge uh let's say like uh uh
Democrat with like a shaky popularity or
or a record whether it's Joe Biden or
someone else and so a lot of people are
looking up and saying well like what
what should the future of the Republican
Party be uh you know are people going to
be backing someone that's not Donald
Trump if that person loses to Trump what
then
um do you have any thoughts as to what
folks who are who think and would like
to act like you do like what their path
should be or course of action well I
mean look I think it's very important
for the future of anything like what I
consider to be conservatism or the
proper character of the Republican party
that Donald Trump not be the party's
nominee again and so working to that end
is extremely important for people who
have some uh stake in the future of the
American right and I think there will be
people who challenge Trump
um and maybe some strong candidates who
challenge Trump but I think it's at this
point you'd have to say it's likely that
Trump will run
and at this point he certainly seems
like he would be the strongest candidate
running I think he's getting somewhat
weaker with time uh you know the the
everybody becomes boring eventually even
the most gifted circus performer can
only do the same things for so long
um and you see some evidence of that but
I wouldn't exaggerate that I think Trump
still has enormous sway uh over voters
on the right
um there's a question about whether
ultimately Republican voters really are
going to want the next election to
essentially be about the last election
um you know when Trump ran in 2016
for all that I had that I had intense
opposition to him and to his character
and to a lot of what he had to say he
was talking about issues that people
wanted to talk about
um he was talking about a set of things
that were actually on the minds of a
fair number of Republican voters at this
point he's talking about his own grudges
and I don't think that gives him the
same kind of of uh at least inherently
the same kind of power that he had
so I think in the first instance it's
important to think about Alternatives as
alternative futures for the party
um and to see them embodied in
particular individuals that encourage
people to run and I think that it's very
important to see a future for the party
Beyond Trump
um you know if that doesn't happen you
know then I think serious conservatives
on the right find themselves in a
familiar place like where we were in uh
in 2016 and after
and that doesn't give you a lot of
options I didn't vote for Donald Trump I
wouldn't do it now either
um but I think that it's extremely
important not to find ourselves in that
situation again and all we can do at
this point is try to persuade people
that it would be crazy for the party
to put Donald Trump before the country
as uh as as the Republican nominee in a
situation where
if it's without Trump I think
Republicans have a very very strong
chance of winning in 2024
but Trump is not popular he's never
really been that popular and with him I
don't think Republicans have nearly that
chance and I don't think they would
deserve it so you know all I can do is
make that case when you talk about how
the folks in your Facebook feed are
talking about different things uh you
know getting themselves up two of us
sets as to how we might be able to
declare a truce in the culture War I
mean there are times when I I say no I
consider saying things like no one wins
a culture War uh um uh you know uh I
want the forward party to be something
of a bridge builder uh and we are
attracting people that I joke uh yuvall
where we're like attracting a tribe of
people that are more allergic to
tribalism
you know because because if you really
like tribal appeals you're like you know
uh yeah like uh heading toward the sides
um do you have any ideas as to how we
could potentially bring people together
and declare a truce you know in a funny
way my hopefulness is rooted in my sense
of how bad things are I think that that
a lot of Americans are very unhappy with
the state of our culture and our
political culture and you know there are
very few people you could find who would
just say things are going great in
America let's just keep doing this
that's a start that's a place to start
to say this can't be what we keep doing
now I think that in an odd way our two
political parties or two major political
parties are stuck in this rut precisely
because we've now lived through an
entire generation of extremely close
elections
um you know the parties learn from
losing big and winning big and that
means that neither party has learned
anything in a very long time because
neither of them has lost big or one big
since the 1990s
every election is close every election
it seems like everything is uh on the
line uh you know the control of Congress
is swung back and forth more swiftly
than ever in American history
we have in a sense two minority parties
now and a politics without winners
everybody loses all the time
you would think the parties would be
very unhappy with that but they actually
feel like they're on the verge of
winning all the time and their senses
let's just do that again but get our
people out a little better and then we
win
um I I think ironically that the first
party to really grasp that it isn't
winning that it is what it's doing is
not working
will be the party that's in a position
to own the future
um
because ultimately a realignment that in
that that creates a durable majority in
America
has to begin from a sense that what
parties are offering now is not
appealing to the public
um and I think there is room for other
institutions
um to advance that case in such a way
that the two parties are going to hear
it we have a two-party system it's going
to be very hard to break that
essentially impossible I mean the
character of our electoral system is
such difficult it's not impossible but
continue we continue well you know I I
think that what a third party ought to
hope for is that it
that the best of itself can be
integrated into one or both of the other
parties
um and when we've seen that kind of
thing happen is when you've seen real
political change
um in in American life when when the
Whigs or the progressives became parts
of the other parties is when they
enabled uh real transformation and and
ultimately realignments and so I I think
there is room to see our way out of the
the kind of
um intense deadlock that we've been in
for a long time now where neither side
has a durable majority it's important to
see that's unusual in American history
at almost any time in our history if you
look at the situation in our politics
there was what political scientists call
a sun party and a moon party a durable
majority and a long-term minority that
has influence in the way that a minority
does the parties have switched roles but
there's usually been a majority and a
minority if you think about the 20th
century real quick Republicans won
almost every presidential election
between 1896 and 1928 Democrats then won
five presidential elections in a row
um and then after that you had a
situation where Republicans were winning
presidential elections and Democrats ran
Congress for 40 years
and then starting in the 1990s we've had
this weird situation it's important not
to take this for granted this isn't how
our politics has to work
um but to see our way out of it we've
got to recognize that it isn't working
and I think the kind of work you're
doing which helps people see that it
doesn't have to be like this that there
are other ways of thinking about what
politics is for
is tremendously important in opening a
path out of this kind of rut that uh the
the two big parties are in I believe
that we'd be much better served if the
Democratic party were two parties or
Publican party were two parties uh and
then there would be a natural home for
people like you frankly that uh
uh
um Trump fans I see uh reasonable
well-intended uh Republicans and
conservatives as the key Pivot Group uh
in American life right now personally
um and I don't think we've been doing
enough for the Peter Myers the Adam
kinzingers the Liz cheneys who have
acted on principle and a lot of it's
because the folks on the left like
Democrats you know those are next to
their name so it's like well you're on
your own and then ended up your
Republican you know like your interests
aren't very well served I mean it really
does not strike me as uh as the way to
go because uh like to me that's the the
key group uh you know like the key group
that can enable a republican control to
risk to
um arrest its decline into like the
thrall of trump
um so uh that so that's at least my
point of view on it is that if you could
break it up into
um you know four parties instead of two
or ideally five parties
um that then you'd be in better shape uh
you've all you're such a like a
reasonable human being if someone wants
to keep up with you your writings you're
clearly not on Twitter which is one of
the things that I'm sure is keeping you
reasonable
how do people keep up with your work
yes thank you very much I I'm not on
Twitter but you can always find me uh at
the American Enterprise Institute where
I work so aei.org and you can look me up
there and everything I write is
available right there for you look at
that you made some fans for aei.org
absolutely try ai.org I I also run a
quarterly Policy Journal called National
Affairs which you can find at
nationalfairs.com
um and that's not my own writing mostly
but it's really worth your while it's a
place for people to think out loud uh
and in some depth about public policy
questions and the kind of conversation
like we've been having here so I think
your listeners would like it that's one
thing I really like about you too is
that you actually have very detailed
policy prescriptions and a vision and
people have described you as one of the
foremost thinkers uh on the conservative
side because you you actually are not
saying look like get rid of government
get rid of this get rid of that like you
know like you actually have genuine
suggestions most all of us which I agree
with in terms of congressional
modernization and other things so thank
you really well thank you I appreciate
that very much
[Music]